hello everyone and welcome to another
remarkable game from round three of this
year's think world cup it is the chosen
one alireza furuja vs levon arunyan and
it is a game uh also one for the aegis
features uh well a very very early uh
surprise by lavon and a very very early
piece sacrifice by alireza and when you
combine the two it uh well uh just uh
delivers a very very interesting game
uh so let's see what happened alireza
has the white pieces and he opens with
e4 we have e5 by levon knight f3 knights
the c6 bishop the c4 going for the
italian game level 1 plays bishop c5 at
the joko piano and now pawn to d3
alireza does not go for the strongest
move but the geography anissimo will
have to do we have knight f6 we have h3
now and uh levon castles knight to c3
and now you get a position where usually
three moves are uh played in every game
that's h6 that's d6 and that's a6 so h6
and d6 are far more common a6 not so
common but also played uh but the move
level one place is uh has been played
only a handful of times in top games and
that is knight to a5 he goes after the
bishop on c4 and it's just a very
annoying thing to see
because
he's allowing knight captures on e5 but
if alireza goes for this then for one
you go right into lavon's preparation
and for two
you don't really uh
well if you don't have this prepared at
home uh you will probably mess it up and
for example if knight captures an e5
queen e7 attacks the knight and now you
don't
have a good way of dealing with this
because if you go back knight to f3 then
just knight captures on c4 will ruin
your pawn structure d captures on c4
also the pawn is now weak and black
regains the pawn and retains a better
position so what do you have what you
would have to do if queen to e7 you
would have to go for this bishop
captures an f7 uh rook captures knight
captures queen captures and then just
castles for example and you would get
this position uh where alireza gave up
two pieces for the rook so he has a rook
for two pieces but he is also up to pawn
so it's a it's an equal game uh but
obviously the one prepared this so you
don't play this and um other moves that
have been tried here aside from knight
captures on e5 are bishop to b3 and
castles but alireza plays pawn to a3 and
that is now a new move so already as of
move 7 we have a completely new game
which is incredible as we are in the
joko pianissimo
so levon goes for knight captures and c4
the bishop is now up for grabs d
captures on c for this double zelda is a
spawn structure here uh but he does gain
full control over the d5 square we have
pawn to d6 and the bishop to g5 pinning
the knight
bishop to e6 going after the c4 pawn and
just queen to d3 developing while
defending
uh and h6 with bishop to h4 and this is
where the game gets uh very very wild
here levon could consider something like
a6 or c6 or a5 or or whatever but the g5
is a and
well it is just too deadly there to give
someone like calireza uh as now uh
you're basically asking for a knight
capture son g5 is coming and this pin
will remain for the rest of the game and
all it is that does go for it uh moving
the bishop back just uh you know gives
the one the full control of over the
game attacks the bishop knight f4 idea
in some lines uh f5 is coming so yeah
you don't want to play this so knight
capture sanji five h captures and the
bishop capture so now uh if you if you
count the pieces you can see that both
players have two rooks uh both players
have a knight in the bishop however
levon has an extra light square bishop
so if if he can defend it that's going
to be that's going to be huge and he
starts with king the g7 usually when you
play this h6 g5 stuff and someone
sacrifices you want to play this king g7
idea uh because uh yeah you can bring
the rook to g8 in some lines and then
bring the king back or you can even play
rook h8 to the h6 the g6 to sort of set
up
some sort of a defense uh because white
can always pile up on the pin piece for
example queen f3 can come knight the d5
can be played and
you you might just fall apart very
quickly so alireza doesn't go for queen
f3 he instead goes for f4 makes sense he
wants to open up the f file maybe put
the rook on f1 and go after the knight
so e captures on f4 and here knight to
e2 this is how he wants the
uh put pressure on the f4 pawn and levon
has to figure out how to defend now uh
black's position is fine black can play
this uh but he has to play with with
absolute surgical precision and levon
plays c6 and that's not the way to do it
it's a very tricky move that uh prepares
the uh arrival of the queen via the a5
square now if you imagine something like
knight captures on f4 if eliza just wins
the pawn let's say
rook f1 is coming then levon just plays
queen a5 check and after the king moves
you don't want to trade queens or
something because you're
attacking and if b4 just bishop captures
of course uh rook on a1 would be hanging
the rooks are not connected so you'd
have to play something like king d1 and
then bishop b6 already uh threatens
queen captures and g5 and all of a
sudden the queen is uh the queen has
unpinned uh herself and is uh joining
the attack or or the defense so after c6
alireza plays the absolute strongest
pawn to b4 he didn't play it on move
four but he does play it now so pawn to
b4 chases away the bishop bishop to e3
adds a defender here and you would be
very happy if levon just uh
captures the pawn on f4 and unpins uh so
then your queen will be able to move and
your knight will be able to move uh but
now just rook to f1 all it is is still
piles up on the f4 pawn king g6 and now
pawn the h4
and now what do you play the problem is
if you play something weird let's say
you play something like a6 then knight
captures on f4 bishop captures and real
captures and you are not surviving this
this is just game over instant resign so
you have to play something and there's
uh
no obvious way to to handle the position
but levon finds one as he usually does
he plays bishop captures on c4 he gives
up a piece this way queen captures on c4
and now pawn to d5 he says your king is
also in the center of the board uh let's
let's attack the white king and now of
course if captures them queen captures
and black is perfectly fine so after d5
alireza goes back queen to b3 and now
levon plays rook to e8 uh
rook to e8 bringing the rook into the
attack putting uh pressure on this e4
pawn uh the maybe a slightly better way
to defend this queen d6 simply because
you are preventing the
uh
the the the capture on f4 the way white
would like it here for example if knight
captures bishop captures and bishop
captures now you just move the queen
queen e7 and if e5 then the knight goes
to e4 and hopefully you survive this
it's not going to be easy but maybe you
can't queenside castles and it's it's an
ugly position to play but maybe you can
do it however after rook to e8 now all
it is just goes for bishop captures on
f4 now the pin is no longer needed
bishop captures knight captures on f4
with check king the h7 and here the
beautiful castles queen side and this is
where the magic happens or rather where
the magic could have happened uh levon
plays knight captures on e4 but any
other move loses
as the position is completely winning
for alireza but it's not an easy move to
find so feel free to pause the video
here and try to find the uh well
pretty much the only winning move for
alireza while i give you a couple of
seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on supporting this
incredible idea and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is knight
captures on d5 look at this knight
captures on the e5 spectacular opening
up the attack towards the f7 pawn and
there's no move you can make here uh
whatever you play uh you're just lost
especially now as the d5 point is pretty
crucial in black setup here and it
doesn't matter if you recapture it if c
captures on d5 rook captures an f7 check
and it's like okay so what but now king
g8 attacks the rook rook captures on d5
and there's no defense here uh you can't
even give up the queen for two rooks
because if king captures rook captures
comes with a discovery so black just
falls apart so what you would have to do
here is move the queen which is just
ugly let's say queen b6 uh so now you
get rook after f5 and there's no uh
playing this now yes you're still up a
knight but with the king here
threatening all sorts of nasty
discoveries even if something like queen
e6 is played there's even queen to f3
then queen to g4 with check rook to h5
checkmate uh threats are in the air uh
it's just resigns so yeah obviously it's
not that easy move to find as alireza
missed it so big congratulations to all
of you who found it but alireza was also
very low on time so he plays knight to
e2 he finds a different way to get uh
his pieces into the attack but now if
played properly levon can defend this
but also live on low on time he doesn't
find it rook to e7 and king to g8 hold
but the move he plays knight to d6 does
not hold or rather it holds except uh if
alireza finds the only winning attempt
that exists in the position and he does
queen to d3 with check and okay what is
queen d3 king h8 queen d4 check king h7
and now knight to g3
uh preparing knight to f5 uh lavon says
all right i've seen all of this i don't
mind queen b6 offering a queen trade
queen d3 check king the g8 and not
knight to f5 now you have to trade
otherwise queen g3 queen g7 so knight
captures we have queen captures on f5
and queen to e3 check so lemon saw all
of this when he played knight to d6 it's
not a problem king b1 and now queen to
e6 defending on f7 and offering a queen
trade so again this is something all of
this levon saw the problem is what he
missed is that alireza can decline the
queen trade and get his rook into the
attack very quickly and levon cannot
bring his rook into the defense very
quickly so already just goes back queen
f2
and now how do you play this uh well uh
getting the rook into the game via some
weird uh maneuvers would be way too long
so he just plays a5 he wants to play
captures on b4 and then open up an
attack maybe against the white king but
now rook d3 a captures on b4 rook to g3
with check and whatever you play is
insufficient if you move the king king
h7 then queen f3 followed by queen to h5
there's no defending this uh it would
just be uh resigns so levon tries king
to f8 at least the f7 pawn is defended
but now rook back to f3
and the problem is you don't have rookie
seven if you had rookie seven then
black's attack might still work but if
rookie seven there's queen d4 threatens
mate mating one and also will pick up
the b for pawn once you attend to the
mate threat so let's say queen h6 now
queen captures on b4 pins the rook and
also threatens rook captures on f7 this
is deadly so after king e8 um you have
to play something to unpin here just
real captures on f7 and after rook
captures rook captures king captures it
seems black is up a rook but it only
seems that way queen captures on b7
check and now if you go up the board of
course rook falls with check if you go
down the board it doesn't help because
first you grab the pawn with check and
once the king moves then you grab the
rook you are up uh three pawns or even
after capturing here you can capture
here
three clean pawns uh completely winning
for alireza so that's what levon missed
when he played that knight the d6 move a
long long time ago uh so okay uh king
after rook to f3 king the g8 displayed
uh he tries uh to give up the f7 pawn at
least it will not come with czech but
alireza shows that it is not possible
rook captures an f7 rook captures an e3
and now just rook to f8 to check king h7
here alireza plays the beautiful rook if
a queen f7 checked and he was in this
position on move 38 that level and
arunian resigned to the game as there is
nothing more to be done here
so truly a spectacular showing it wasn't
a one-sided game there were ways for
levon to get back into the game uh but
he he missed those few ideas but that's
the problem of course you spend you burn
so much time both of them finish the
game like how it is had 30 seconds on
the clock level and had like one minute
uh so
they were basically playing blitz so uh
you know for for the last 15 20 moves so
it was pretty pretty crazy and here yeah
it's a very very clean idea you resign
because if the queens get traded then
just a rook captures on f7 and it seems
like you're going to go into a rook and
again because if rook captures king
captures rook on f7 alireza has h5
that's the problem that that comes with
check now the king has to either step
away or capture the pawn and then rook
captures you are just up a full rook and
if you don't do this after queen f7
check if you just play king to h6 uh of
course you just get checkmated check
here captures characters king h7 rook f7
checking here and of course queen g7 uh
will be checkmate
so while staff levon uh tried to to
to play in his usual style gave alireza
the deadly there with this g5 move but
uh this was uh i mean it works in many
positions but this is not one such
position here knight captures on g5 and
the white is just uh
white is just better
uh so yeah once again i hope you guys
enjoyed it for those of you who did not
watch my previous video do watch my
previous video it's uh one of the
you know fiercest games we've ever shown
uh and uh for uh but you know in case
you don't have the time these are the
standings uh after uh round three so
hans niemann takes the lead uh wesley so
uh with two points uh magnus carlsen uh
yandy pogba reservation maxima shilogram
and linear dominguez are tied with one
and a half and with one point levon
aaron fabiano corona and shahriar
mamidyarov okay now i've realized that
now that i've shown you the standings
even though if you haven't seen the
previous video uh you might get some
ideas but what are you gonna do
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it uh i would like to thank
gerald watts would thanks uh paul
sertanovich and bliss 44 chess for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
sinkfield cup
until it finishes so thank you all i
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day